all right hello my name is ty Gailey and
i'm here today to talk about packets and
packet developments his talk is long
overdue
the packet system has existed for years
and been used to great effect within
wolfram users have noticed this and
they've been clamoring for information
about how it works and how to use it
I'm happy to say that we are now
exposing the packet system for users
documenting how to use it this talk is
the first step in that process so the
packet system was created years ago
originally to to allow us to provide
updates for data categories like country
data the is so called data packets of
old which still exist and are still
update are using the packet system but
from the beginning it was designed to
handle arbitrary content in particular
Wolfram language packages things that we
might have called applications in the
past and until today packets are heavily
used within Wolfram research to talk
about that a little more in a second
we're now documenting exposing the
system we are going to be creating a
packet repository that will accept user
submissions and we're very much hoping
to create a vibrant ecosystem of packets
that are easily discoverable
downloadable accessible for users most
modern programming languages have some
sort of pack of the repository system
you know package repository system like
that I'm hoping to create something like
that for wolfram and we're very much
hoping that developers like you will
help us fill this out all right so if
you are creating any kind of add-on
content for wolf products that doesn't
fit neatly into one of our other
repository categories if you have a
single function function repository is a
great place for that or if you have a
larger piece of functionality we
definitely want you to create it in the
form of a packet alright so just quickly
some of the ways we use packets within
the Wolfram system we componentize the
product and build system and
it's very convenient for the build
system as well to build every whole
bunch of different components separately
and then organize them into the product
it allows us to push out immediate
updates to functionality the changes
much more rapidly than wolfram you know
product releases great example of that
is the Wolfram cloud wolfing cloud
changes all the time and that
necessitates necessitates changes in the
client but you know Mathematica in
product client of the cloud so we're
constantly pushing out updates to the
cloud object Pacolet that that support
the client side of cloud communication
critical bug fixes we've used it quite a
bit for pushing out critical bug fixes
after releases I mean most people don't
even realize that we do that we quietly
slip those things out onto your system
we've used it for a new functionality
that doesn't really need to wait for a
Mathematica release we've used it quite
a bit for updating documentation after
the fact there are over 200 packets in
the Mathematica 12.1 layout and there's
over 2,300 packets on the wolfmann
packet server now that's not 2300
different pieces of functionality
there's many of them occur in multiple
versions but there are 2300 packets on
this on the server just text large
enough for people to see it's at 150%
it's supposed to video of time receive a
good time you find what it says anyway
said you know it doesn't count all right
so packet documentation now finally
right this is this is the thing people
are really here to see in the beta that
is in this kindest conference there is
no even product documentation for the
packet system I have however written a
tutorial style document at that URL that
I published into the cloud it's perhaps
a little formatting challenged but I
just wanted to get it down on paper it's
a document that complements this talk it
goes into considerably greater detail
about all these topics and things I
don't be able to get to in this talk
this is a pretty good opening
opening starred in the documentation of
the packet system so it all interested
please read that we will have full
Wolfram style documentation coming in
12.1 alright introduction to packets it
took me a while to get to what they
actually are there are units of Wolfram
functionality packaged it up in a way
that allows them to be easily
distributed and installed and updated
and also when they're deployed they
integrate seamlessly into the wolfman
environment essential element of what
makes a pack that a packet is this
packet the info WL file and we'll call
it WL file it's hard to have it to break
cuz I've been calling the packet and put
out my for a long time
you can certainly name your packet info
dot am trying to stick with the WL
terminology in this but if I say dot in
whatever it's works either way it's
which is a very small simple file of
metadata describes the packet and it
also describes what it requires from the
system and it describes the ways in
which it extends the environment take a
bunch of files and you throw a packet
into a got WL file next to it you know
back
we call the thing in Mathematica or in
the Wolfram engine that manages packets
updates installs and makes them
available to the system they call it the
package manager all right so packets are
versioned this is you know the version
number of a packet is an essential
probably the most essential aspect of
the packet because the packet manager
always uses the highest version number
it finds having multiple versions having
a packet version be part of its identity
allows us to have side-by-side
installation of multiple versions of a
packet and you probably already do have
more than one copy of more than one
instance of packet installed on your
system because one might be you know
four version 11.3 ones for version 12
ones for one operating system ones for
another they can live side by side on on
your on your layout packets have
requirements if how could info file
declares certain things that it requires
that the system it can have a dependent
you can say I need I need this this
system ID you know this operating system
I prepared this version of Mathematica
or this range of versions of Mathematica
you can also say I require a certain
product name
the question is can you can your program
specify I need a certain version of a
package and there's two aspects to this
this could get into a long side
discussion it's two aspects this one is
is can you can you in demand can you ask
a certain version of a pack that be
installed and yes don't really show that
in this talk but Pacolet install lets
you say I want this pack the name with
this version and it'll be installed when
it comes time to load it though it's a
it's a separate issue about it's a
difficult issue and since Mathematica
says runtime environment it might be
long-lived you might have another
version of this code already loaded your
package is now going to be used by the
user and you say I need version 3.1 of
this packet but these are might have
already loaded 3.0 over 3.2 or something
it's it's a little tricky there's not
it's not a great answer to that question
you you can manage the packet see
installed you can write programs that
manage that the complement of packets
that are installed the specific versions
but whether or not you can guarantee
that when you you call needs blah
whether you absolutely sure that that's
the only version and you know you're
gonna be loading it's tricky we're
trying to think about a good solution
for that
so so the point is that packets that
don't match these requirements are
basically invisible if you do pack would
find function we'll see later you won't
even say I didn't show up packets have
extension so in extensions which we'll
see in a moment describe the way back
that describes the way in which it
extends the Wolfram system you know I
can declare I have some pallets I have
some you know WL code I have some you
know Wolfen libraries things like that
and finally that this can be disabled
and enabled without deleting them so if
there's a packet that's not behaving
well you can disable it if you are
testing something you want to make sure
a packet doesn't get loaded you can
disable enable that later you don't have
to worry
about deleting it from the system
alright so this is basic operations of
packet managers essentially the
fundamental principle is that whenever
the user or the system looks for a
resource like a file the pack of
managers consulted first and pack the
manager says ok I will look for packets
that might have this resource it finds
all the packets that have it calls out
the ones that don't match the
requirements of the system it calls out
any ones that are disabled and it always
picks the highest version number and
uses that this is much smarter lookup
than a simple dollar path based search
and it's important that the packet
manager is consulted first
so you see documentation that says
Mathematica looks on dollar path well
that's not really right Mathematica asks
the packet manager first IND and if the
packet manager says if the packet
manager says I don't have that I can't
find that file in a packet then Nautica
looks at dollar path alright so by
design packets are mostly invisible to
users beyond installation what I mean by
that is that it's essentially a passive
thing you don't actively operate as a
user on packets you install them but
once you've installed it it just weaves
itself into the system in such a way
that the resources that it has get found
through the normal means I install a
packet I just type needs some context
right I don't I don't even need to care
where that context came from I don't
need to know anything about how the
system is packetized I just ask for
things that I want and they show up
documentation just shows up Alice they
just show up in the system I don't have
to explicitly know about packets and say
ok give me this from this Pacolet
although there are circumstances but you
might want to do that all right I'm
gonna get it ahead of myself a little
bit here but I want to talk about some
changes in version 12.1 because if
people hear well from people here who a
program with packets and there are some
things that are different
making some significant changes to the
pakka system and version 12.1 first is
that there is a whole set of functions
that people use to operate on packets
we'll be talking about them later
they have moving he's doing the packet
manager context they're now moving to
the system context to be you know
first-class citizens but the old pack of
manager names are still supported so if
you've written code they called you know
packet manager back to something that
code will still work
the syntax of packet in code files is
slightly changed using strings now on
the left-hand sides of rules where they
were symbols before but the old format
is still supported peco's should still
work it's also the case that packets in
the new format will work in older
versions of Mathematica but this thing
in reg which you've probably already
noticed is that I highlighted this
because this is where if anyone has
written any code that operates on
packets programmatically this is code
that might break in language
representation of a packet is now an
expression with head packet object it
used to be back to if you written code
its operating on packets and it's
expecting to see an expression with head
Packard you have some code if head if
something is Pacolet that code is gonna
break you have to ask if packet object
and that's going to be different in 12.1
and earlier so if you want code that
operates with 12.1 and older versions
you're gonna have to you know write a
little if statement there's your own
little function that ask you know if
it's packet or packet object alright
alright so the packet input WL file as i
said before it's the presence of this
file that makes something a packet it's
a very simple file you can also name it
patty so let's take a look at a trivial
packet info file now you
I've got name and version highlighted in
red here because those the required
fields every packet must have a name and
must have a version the name must be
unique in the world of packets
can have its ass notice the version is a
string it's not a number it's a string
you can have up to five digit blocks you
know one point zero point five point
seven point three or something like that
alright and the extension section this
is where you describe you tell the
packet manager what things were packet
provides and you could probably figure
this out a kernel extension is is the
way of saying I have Wolfram language
code I have contexts that need to be
mapped to files in in my packet and so
you say so this is package called file
utilities and I'm saying I export some
context called file utilities back to
now there's no reason there's no
requirement that this context file
utilities match the name of the packet
or anything of the sort
that often be the case but there's no
requirement of that the root Aero kernel
thing when the packet manager looks so
someone says needs file utilities the
packet manager will say ah I know
there's a packet that has that context
and how is it going to map fire
utilities back to the full path to the
file well it knows where the packet is
installed and the kernel extension has a
route that says that's a path within the
packet to the content for this type of
extension so this would be a kernel
subdirectory of your packet
now all extensions have most extensions
have a default route the typical named
place where content for that type of
extension would reside and kernel is the
convention people should write packets
with their dot m files in a kernel
directory but for backward compatibility
reasons with old-style applications and
various formats
I couldn't make kernel the default route
so if you have a kernel subdirectory
with dot M files in it you have to say
root goes to kernel but most every other
path with the extension type the default
route is the place that you would
normally put the files anyway so you
wouldn't wouldn't have to specify route
but for a kernel extension that is not
the default so you will have to save
what goes to graph all right so trivial
Pacolet it's just has really one piece
of content a dot n file
and and this is what the director layout
might look like as you can guess you
have some father utilities parent
directory which the name of that
directory is meaningless it could be
anything the packet is defined by the
patent WL file and in a cross-table
directory and a file utilities WL file
within that right now here's the
slightly more complex map an info file
in red I've got highlighted wolf
inversion system Rd in product name
these are the three fields that you
specify requirements for your Pacolet so
a wolfram version goes to twelve dot
star that means any version 12 in fact
twelve just twelve it's the same as
twelve dot stock right you can always
there's always an implied dot star at
the end of every version specification
you can also say twelve plus that would
be any version of starting with twelve
and onward you can use - you can say
twelve - any twelve you know back you
can have there's a bit of a small little
language you used to specify your
wolfram version requirements system ID
that's obvious so this packet would
never be installed or used on on any
system other than Windows or Windows 64
product name you say wolfram engine for
example that we don't really document
product names but our products have
different names internally and so if you
had a packet that's maybe only
appropriate for a system modeler or
something you could use product name to
specify that it was only compatible with
system modeler and then you can have
various fields create a description and
your support link or something there's a
lot of fields that you that are
described in a packet info file but they
really don't have most of them don't
have any intrinsic meaning you know you
can also have a custom field I have some
custom field here there's nothing to
keep you from creating your own fields
in your packet info file
all right so extensions there's various
types of extensions and the point of
these extensions is that you you want
your package to just weave itself into
the system right so current looks sense
you've already seen if you declare your
kernel extension then needs your context
law automatically work a front-end
extension if you have palettes system
you know style sheets a front-end
resources like that
you can you just put them in the
property name directory and and you
declare a front-end extension and
they'll automatically show up in the
front-end documentation same way if you
practice documentation you want a lot of
manage to show up in the in the help
viewer a path extension is a way to say
I want files within my packet to be
found as if they were on dollar path
let's show an example of that later on
if you have library link libraries you
can just clear live as an extension you
don't have to go modify a dollar library
path and things like that you just
declare that your lobby link extension
and then load library will find your
libraries J link if you have a Java
subdirectory and some Java classes in it
Java files JD will automatically find
them if you just declared you have a J
link extension you don't have to call
add to class path a resource extension
is a little different sort of a generic
resource of any kind in your packet and
there's a there's a packet resource
function that you use to look up named
resources to show example of that in a
second and you can also create custom
extensions if the package is not going
to choke if there's some extension type
that's never seen before and there's a
very good reason for doing that I
probably won't have time to talk about
it but it's described in my tutorial you
can implement a plug-in type system
where where you can look across all
packets in the system and say ok tell me
all the packets that have this type of
extension and then you could resource
that you wanted other packets to be able
to provide and plug into your framework
all right so here's a much more complex
example Pacolet with a bunch of
different types of extensions we have a
kernel context a kernel extension has
multiple contexts that have exports we
have documentation front-end paths and a
resource extinction so if you look at
the resource extension it's just a way
resources extension is basically just a
way to say I want to map a symbolic name
like Sun to a path within my Pacolet
we'll see an example of looking that up
so you can probably guess what the this
is what the directory layout for this
packet would typically look like we've
got a cross directory it says my package
that WL I guess they were supposed to be
two files in that directory the front
end extension has a front end
subdirectory this front end slash
palettes this is just the standard front
end layout right you just have to
conform to the fun in the layout the
finite expects you have a directory
called palette style sheets and it's the
same layout that you see in Mathematica
product the same thing with
documentation I just conform to the
standard directory structure that the
documentation system expects and then I
have a Resources directory this is for
the this is for the resource extension
and you saw that that had expected an
images subdirectory with with files so
this is what that directory layer Maps
basically directly to the the extensions
that we saw a minute ago alright so I do
actually have this pack lid sitting in a
directory laid out on my system so I'm
going to install it just to show how how
this works alright so there's a function
in the packing manager called pack pack
lid which takes a directory that
contains a packet in profile it crunches
it together to create a packet file and
then pack would install I can use to
install that
and you can see the result is this
packet object of expression which is a
representation in the language of a
packet so what has happened now is I had
a directory sitting somewhere on my hard
drive with some files in it about the
info I kept it up and then I installed
it when I did pack in the stole it got
put into the packet repository just
often you know you dollar use replace
area so now this packet is installed and
so I want to show that the resources
that that pack that declared are all
present it had a palette called super
palette I just showed up the minute I
did that right this is not an
interesting palette so I won't bring it
out that palette wasn't there before but
is there now if I say needs my package
and call example function it works or
that was a function to find in my
package
this is the path extension I can say I
can now use the name of the packet as
the first component in a relative path
so this basically it's as if you had
appended to dollar path the root
directory of your packet so I can just
now say example pack of slash hello dot
txt file gets filed and this is an
example of the resource extension
it might be worthwhile to go back see
here I declared that I had a resource
extension which is just arbitrary things
that will be found using the packet
resource function and I just cleared
that I had some name son which should
map to images slash Sandow jpg so then
in code I just say packet resource and
give my packet name and I give the name
of the thing so the this type of
declarative programming is extremely
useful in my code that uses the packet I
don't need to know anything about the
structure internal structure of the
packet the packet can change the
location of this file as long as the
packet info dot and file all you know
changes to properly reflect the new
location code like this will just always
work I just I can refer to this thing by
a name instead of by its path alright so
that's an just an example of the you
know the basics of how these things work
you create a layout you define okay
packed into a file and when you install
it it's just woven itself into the
system so that all the components can be
found without any any effort alright so
a brief note about dot pack with files
so when you know when a packet is
deployed it's just it's not it's just a
directory but a convenient form for for
distributing in and deploying them is is
a dot packet file which is just a
compressed archive of a single file pack
pack that is a function that does this
there's also unpack Packer but I
sometimes hear people say things that
imply that they think making a packet
means creating a dot Pepa file it's not
true making a packet means just throwing
a packet info file into a directory now
you've got a packet Packard's not
defined as a dot package file that's
just a convenient mechanism for
distributing these things
oh no your packet can have an
arbitrarily complex structure a single
pack lid you know in a single dot pack
the file pack of itself can be
arbitrarily complex but I mean we just
saw a pack that that had multiple
directories and subdirectories but you
can only put one packet into a dot
Packer file it's a zip the question up
here is it's basically about the
internal format of a dot packet file the
answer is it's a zip file if you change
the extension to dot zip you can unzip
it please don't don't use anything but
pack Packer to create packets you could
use some zip utility but pack Pacolet
handle some things for it like we want
the zip archive convention is not well
specified and so pack pack later you can
handle things like preserving the
executable bit on programs
it handles Unicode files Unicode
characters and file names and all that
so please use PAC pack then it also
creates a pack of file dot pack a file
whose name includes the version and
their qualifier and it corrects it it
creates the what we consider the proper
name for the file so please use PAC
Pacolet alright so installing and
updating pack let's pack let me install
is the function that installs a packet
or updates one if a newer version is
available in version 12.1 packet update
is going away it's still supported in
the packet manager context for
compatibility but the function is not is
going away pack install will do both
duties both originally installing and
updating the packet so packet install is
very fast if no update is available it
generally does not consult people
sometimes maybe I don't want to call
pack install all scatter that in my code
because that's gonna be really slow the
system has to go ask the server if a
pack that's available it does not ask
the server it just looks at a local
cache of data now I say generally does
not contact the package server because
pack a server gets contacted every now
and then like once in a session for sure
and so it's conceivable that if you call
packet install that you might be the guy
who pays the cost hitting the package
server and generally we that rarely
happens but it's not impossible that any
individual call to packet install might
trigger and I call to update the packet
info which might take a second or
something from the server almost all the
time however Packer install is extremely
fast because it does not touch the
server in any way it gets downloaded and
packets are stalling to dollar user base
package directory this location is
probably changing in 12.1 I'm not even
really mentioning that because you
shouldn't care you should always use
dollar user base packets directly to
find where packets are installed
don't assume you know where they go
alright so there here's some various
uses of packet install you can pass a
packet name and this is the typical way
that would get a packet from any server
and a pack a site that's known to your
system you can also install directly
from a dot packet file if I created pack
a file and give it to you give it to
distribute in my organization users can
just install it directly as a path you
can stall from the URL if you have a URL
that points to a pack with file and you
can install from a cloud object this
doesn't so it's all my stuff I'm talking
about only works in 12.1 or or maybe
even like my 12.1 and not your 12.1
so i can't promise that i'm describing
the package system you know as it will
be not necessarily
instant in time this one asked this one
thing doesn't work quite right all right
so that's packet install finding packets
packed with fine is the function that
finds packets on your system
so here I've called pakka find
interpreter interpreter is a packet all
the interpreter functionalities package
that was a single packet so what there's
three things packet find returned three
packet objects now surely I don't have
three copies of interpreter in the
layout and of course I don't these other
these other instances are elsewhere
these are going to be in my packet
repository I run this and I didn't try
so the first one that's the one in the
in the Mathematica 12.1 layout I have
two other older copies of interpreter in
my packet repository so why do I have
old copies of interpreter my packet
repository well they were probably
updated they're probably updates for
interpreter in like twelve point o or
eleven point three or something like
that right I still have those copies of
Mathematica I've gotten interpreter
updates for those things when packet
install installs an update it generally
deletes the older version but it won't
delete the older version if the older
version is clearly not if the newer
version is clearly not a replacement for
the older version the new version is you
know version 12 plus and the old one is
version 11 it won't delete the version
11 one because it it doesn't pack a
measure doesn't know where you still
have mathematical eleven whether you
might still want to run Mathematica 11
so it doesn't want to just blindly
delete all old copies of backwards but
it will if if it's it's seen as clearly
a an update to an old one all right so
pack the fine has a lot of options to
control what types of packets you want
to find and I'm not going to go into any
of this stuff but you can ask for
packets in certain location you can ask
for packets with certain extensions you
can ask for packets with certain
creators or or whatever there's a lot of
ways that you might want to search out
packets you can also use simple wildcard
notation this is all the packets in my
system that start with end and again
there's a lot of duplicates here because
some of these are in the package
repository the other thing that you
might want to do is to look for packets
on packet servers Packer find remote is
a function that does that so if I say
Packer finder more for interpreter I see
two now there's two packet objects with
the same number I think that I think if
I run this again I'll only see one at
the time I ran that I had two Pacolet
sites known to my system most users only
have one the regular wolfram public
packet server but I have I might many
people internal the wolfram we have
other packet servers in the company that
are visible they're used for non public
distribution of packets at the time I
ran that I had two servers but I removed
that server so this is just the one
that's sitting on the public server so
you might think that common use people
might have is to find out in advance
whether update is available for a packet
but there's a utility function that does
that packet check update so instead of
instead of calling packer find remote
and seeing if the list was not empty you
can just call packer check update so
that's the utility function that tells
you whether or not dates available
returns a list of all possible updates
so if it's the empty list then your
interpreter or your packet is up-to-date
getting information about Packer there's
a lot of ways to get information about
packets there's a packet information
function which returns a big list of
rules about the thing
you can also use it with a selector like
this where the second argument is is the
selector that just gives the value that
you want and this also does not work in
12-point all you'd have to say you know
location slash dot packing information
but this selector notation does work in
12.1 or at least you know my 12.1 and
then the information function we have
this general purpose information
function which is overloaded to work
with all sorts of different expressions
in the language it also works on packets
but to use information I couldn't say
information of interpreter because
information had no idea what I was
talking about I have to get a packet
expression right so I say first a pack a
find of interpreter that gives me the
packet expression of the packet object
for the you know sort of active version
of interpreter on my system and if I say
information of that then I get this
lovely little data set type a
representation of all of the fields in
the pack now it's generally not the case
that users really deal with this stuff
anyways right you don't people most
people have no idea interpreter present
they don't care they don't want any no
but there are times as a developer
especially when you do want to sort of
programmatically ask questions about
packets Jessie
yes what yes that's a good question
yes it's pakad find is sorted in order
version number and the the first one is
the highest version of version but to be
stripped it's not strictly true because
by default if I say pack the find it
only returns you know enabled pack lets
it only returns packets that are visible
to my my operating system things like
that but if you there's options you can
use for pacifying to still the rule that
you can say enabled arrow false and you
can see all the packets that are
disabled on your system so in that case
the first one is not the active one
because none of those packets would be
active but it's always sorted in version
number order no there's no built-in way
because that's essentially well below
the concern of the packet manager right
Pecha manager just knows about your
telling about you your context i my
commander doesn't probe into yeah just
to figure out what function or
surveillance context and what you can do
which you could once if you know the
context of function is in which is
easily done you you could say pack would
find and then context arrow that context
and then you'd see the Packer said let's
apply that context so you sort of do it
as a two-step thing you just say context
of some function right there's a
function in this spoken language it
gives you the context
alright Pacolet sites so so when you
call path install a pack to find remote
where the path of a and packet manager
looks for that packet in the set of
known packet sites like I said before
most users just have one known pack of
sight which is our Wolfram public pocket
server and packet sites is the function
that returns the list of known Pacolet
sites so we get this pack that site
object expression back you can use pack
a site add a packet slight removed to
manage the set of known sites they said
it's persistent for one session to the
neck so sticky so you don't once you
once you add a pack with site it sticks
around until you remove it so the reason
the call pack aside add is if your
organization or you or whatever wanted
to create your own pack with sites
distribute packets within your
organization say then you would have
people call pack let site add to add
that site and then they could get
packets from that site and I'm going to
show an example of this I say this is
easy to do so I better back that up have
a quick demo here setting up a packet
site but it is in fact easy to separate
packet site because there's no logic
required on the server side our packet
server has a little bit of logic and
logging and things like that
checking stuff but it's not strictly
necessary have any logic at all on the
server side packet side can be as simple
as a web server civil web server or it
can be just a file shared directory and
that is the example I'm going to show so
here I have
so here I have a directory I don't know
if you can see this but there's a
directory called packets and I've thrown
a few packets in there and it's a random
set of packets I had kicking around on
my machine so this is going to become my
packets site I create a package
directory and I throw in all the pack of
files the docker file said my
organization has created or whatever
that I wanted to make available to users
and I call this function called
buildpack with site files in the packet
manager context this is not a system
function you have to dig into the packet
magic context to get it I just point at
that package site directory now what
this does is it creates these two files
packets like Diane and package site MZ
which is just the compressed version of
that file it's all this required to
serve back to the site and if I go back
to my directory was see now that packets
like da dam and packets like that MZ
have been created in that directory next
to the packets directory so I now have a
packet say I'm going to say packets I
add and I'm gonna call packets I'd
update because and this is I think
obviously a miss feature because every
time I do this packet side dad does not
call pakka site update packet site
updates the function that says ok give
me the cash of your data so I can store
it locally and packet side add I think
when I wrote that I think I was
originally thinking that you'd want to
be able to add some sites and not have
to touch them all right then but you
always have to immediately call packet
side update after call pack that's like
that so I think I'll almost certainly
make packet side add call side update
internally because when even when I was
coming up with this talk I did packet
side add and then I tried to use it as
like that's not enough times to
immediately realize I didn't call pepper
side update so called packet side up say
that lends my system know about the
files on that site and now if I say pack
the find remote minecraft link now
there's two here the 102 seven that one
is actually on the public server right
it's this 101 5 version that is that is
on my pack website my local site and if
I once again if I do you know the
location selector on these
see one is on packets irrelevant economy
other one is that this file URL so if I
did if I did packet install minecraft
link I'm going to get the 102 seven from
the public server because it's verse
number but you know you get the idea if
I if there wasn't a higher version on
the public server then any calls to pack
it up
install would get the one from my local
site so that's it's all you have to do
to create a package site
it's just put a bunch of files together
in a package directory run that build
site files function and then you know
figure out a way that users can can see
it I could just I've done this risk with
a file URLs but I could easily have just
any old web server running and just
expose that directory be the web server
and then you know users would just say
pakka site add and give the URL to that
directory and and it would work so it is
actually very simple and very feasible
for organizations create their own
Packer site as a distribution mechanism
for packets I mean great convenience of
that is that you don't have to them yes
you can put packets like PAC pack the
files in some plays until people to get
them but it's very convenient bill to
refer to packets by name no pack would
install my packet and for that to work
there has to be on a packet so all right
so developing packets well let's do
often have a simple layout and they're
easily to create by hand I've been
creating pockets by hand in this talk or
at least you know pre created packets by
hand use your favorite IDE or editor to
edit the whatever files you've got just
put them in a certain layout but Wolford
workbench is a great environment for
wolfing language development and it does
have built-in tools for package
development tools are a little bit out
of date when they're created many years
ago but updates are pending and i still
recommend that people use both and
workbench you have to sort of we have to
understand you understand pack list to
use Wolfen work much because it isn't
really going to hold your hand perfectly
right well that's why I'm talking about
Wolfram workbenches the Wii clips
plug-in that's what that's a name for
the Wolfram the Eclipse plug-in and so
it's just saying it does and well I'm
gonna go to work in example Packer in
just a second envelope in workbench but
there is lots of room for developers to
create tools and plugins to assist
Packer development and here's some ideas
you know automatically create a packet
info file from a directory
you could pretty well look at a
directory and say I can figure out what
this package should look like right you
can verify this syntax and completeness
of a packet info file you could
automatically create a basic directory
layout you know create packet structure
you know kernel is on it and we create a
basic packet structure for a kernel type
Pacolet there's already a function
called packetized in the function
repository that creates very simple
packet out of a function definition so
we're really hoping that people will run
with this and you can create tools and
things that help simplify the process of
packet development authoring and
building documentation this is the
Bugaboo right this is by far the most
complex part of packet developing and
the reason for that is that the
documentation this ships with Wolfram
products is authored in a very
specialized format and then it's
processed by a tool to create the in
product format and the authoring tools
are highly specialized for a Wolfram
research processes and and the
processing tool is also highly
specialized and so we definitely want
authors to pack us to be able to create
documentation that looks like Wolfram
format and to do that you really need to
use this pipeline or at least tools that
we give you that run the pipeline preps
and some simplified version and such
tools are coming but at the moment we
don't really have that that solution so
we are working on a package with the
tools that you need I wanted to try to
show it here today but it's too cold
it's not it's not my area I thought I
could throw something everybody
it defeated me in the short time that I
had to try to pull that together but in
the meantime you have two choices you
can use wolf and workbench
I'm sure I mean that to me sounds like a
bug that I can't promise will be fixed
in the first I mean we will we will
create a tool this is supposed to do it
right and there may be a tail of adding
features and fixing things that people
find out that's kind of a that's an
issue that would obviously need to be
fixed but if it's you know you say
there's a bug now we'll have to make
sure that that book gets fixed in the
tool right but another alternative is to
not use the word documentation for right
now I hate to say this because we really
want users to use the wolf and
documentation front we can't really tell
you to use the docking station format
and not give you tools to to create it
but you can just author notebooks in
whatever format you like and if you put
them in the layout in your documentation
directory in the layout that matches the
expectations of the system and this is
discussed in more detail in my tutorial
document they'll just work they won't
look quite right in the documentation
system but they will function we don't
really want people to do that but it is
a good stopgap until the tooling is
better I think this is my this is my
[Music]
yeah this would be there would be love
to have a pack lid called something like
no Pacolet documentation tools they
would have functions that would let you
say you know they would have a palette
to help you author in the correct style
then create default empty pages for
various time here's the weather here's a
you know blank tutorial page as a blank
function page a blank guide page and
that you could edit those and then it
would crunch them into the in product
format that sort of thing
alright so lets me go to work banshee
I'm gonna give it a gonna build a packet
in workbench with documentation real
quickly here so here's workbench now you
may not be able to see this but you know
you get the idea
well the workmanship test would be on a
different a different release schedule
they're not tied to Mathematica releases
so it's just a question when we get
around to making some tweaks into
workbench
I don't have a timeline for that alright
so I'm going to say file new other now I
have since because I've worked
Benj installed I have this Wolfram
category so I'm going to say application
project really should say packet
projects this is step one you have to
know that this means packet project
right so I'll say next and I think I'll
call it my Pacolet I think that was what
I just I didn't thing it says it says
create packing for dam I want that and
create documentation I want that I don't
need a test notebook for now alright so
I say ok so now it's created this packet
layout now one thing about this is that
the packet info dot M file is sitting
next to the my package directory that is
not the modern style I want it to be
inside that dirty so I'm gonna put it in
it by hand so now I got this is the
package directory it's got a
documentation subdirectory a kernel
subdirectory with a dot M with an init
dot M file in it and in a pack of input
and file along side of it and what
workbench has a pack that info editor
that lets gives me fields for doing this
I'm going to just for the moment click
this tab so I can just see the raw text
so here is my
stocke pack it in for I need to say a
kernel extension right I'm not gonna
just say this is not really gonna be a
functioning pack that I'm doing this
really for the documentation so I create
a kernel extension with the context now
there's an issue about the layout of
this thing
the my pocket item file is not in the
kernel directory there's this india10
file internal directory quick note about
UNITA m-files there evil never use one
you know mm files do not have no place
in the packet world it's a it's kind of
a hack that's created years ago to fix
an issue about half lookups you should
have no need for an M file pack of
manager you tell the pack of magic we're
done in files are and so but this
creates a kind of an old style layout
with a kernel in anytime directory
really what we want is to put this in
here and then get rid of this these
inattentive files have this double
double pack you know get my packet back
tick mark it's just an ugly thing we
don't have any need for any of that all
right I need to say I need to say root
Aero kernel in this extension here but
I'm not gonna bother with that because I
don't care I'm not actually gonna run
the damn file all right so now see this
documentation tab down here so workbench
has tools that actually work nicely to
create regular real packet documentation
so I'm going to click on my symbols
directory I'm going to say add page so
let's say I had a function called my
funk so I say add page
and crunches away and there's my my
phone page and I can create a new guy
page if I want consciously waiting crazy
and you can see that in here those files
are showing up now I got a guides and a
reference pages symbols things so I
didn't have to know anything about the
layout of these pages and so I had me
stub pages on if I open them but open
this in Mathematica launched here so you
get this is what it looks like now
there's a pallet in workbench called
documentation tools it has this silly
dynamic warning tulip out there I can
use to Mac there is this documentation
for this pallet format and how it works
in workbench so I can edit this file and
build a standard looking documentation
file in Mathematica I'm not going to do
that so when I'm done with my
documentation there's this application
tools tool here and I'm going to pick my
project which is my Pacolet and I'm
going to say build it crunches away it
takes a little while it's just two files
it takes a little while
are there any questions while this is
running
well I'm this will be linear with a
number of documentation files I don't
know how its scales with the size of the
file I mean it presumably it's just
linear with the size yeah it takes a
while to do I mean it's just uh it
builds finished now it took 25 seconds
so most of that was that was the
processing of the documentation so my
packet is now
it's built so if I went back to
Mathematica I just have one really
cracking my last slide here packard
directory ad is the function that tells
the Packer managed to look for packets
in a non-standard location and the
reason use packet Oread extremely useful
for developers not useful for users
the reason use packet draft realities
which is what I'm doing right now I have
some development directory from my
packet and I'm editing the files in
place in the layout of the packet and I
want to be able to just go back to my
mathematical sessions they get my
context and load the change file over
and over again right so I need to tell
the package manager this look for
packets in this directory so I say
packet rectory add for my development
directory and now I can just go back to
Mathematica and I can't everything I
like Packer just show up immediately
just as if I had installed the packet
you don't want to have to pack and
install your packet somewhere else just
to see the last little edit you made to
the dot M file this is this is very much
like the analog of prepend $2 path in
the nonprofit world yeah
no there isn't the equivalent of doctor
there I see what you're saying pack
ejector we had returns there isn't I
should probably add that I think I mean
there isn't a way to see the set of
added pack of directories pack adductor
we add returns the set but there isn't
actually a function now that just tells
you that I should probably okay III
maybe I just might make packet directory
out of no arguments return the list yeah
all right very good question the
question is does it and the answer is
yes this is very important
pack the directory add wins ties and
this is very useful if you if you have a
version of my packet installed somewhere
else maybe it's in the layout maybe or
its installed in repository version 1.0
and I'm working on the new version but I
haven't Eddie's the packet info file to
make it version 1.1 if I say package
rectory add it will the version my
version 1.0 will be found ahead of the
one anywhere else so pack adductor
headwinds ties in terms of version
numbers right now I've run out of time I
was going to show if I point at this
pack that I just built in workbench the
docs will show up in the system just
like just like you'd expect but I don't
have time to do that it's a run out but
I just want to mention briefly this pack
of the repository so we do we do have a
pack of repository under development you
really want to create a thriving
collection of packets something like
pipe I new gather every language has
this this type of package repository and
we want to create one of our own and
hopefully we'll have lots of submissions
contributions and people so go forth and
create packets and help us grow the
Wolfram system thank you very much
you